[Music]
what's up by general hospital you uh
general i mean i mean uh sorry
children's hospital but let's talk about
let's talk about general hospitals okay
okay yeah no we can talk about that in
my opinion one of the best of the soaps
ever yeah
now let's transition into children's
hospital
now back to general hospital
now back to children's hospital
uh you're on the takeaway by the way oh
that was super fun it's what i
do you uh i'm curious you were on the
cast but now you're directing episodes
as well and i'm i've always wondered how
do you get the respect of the crew
that's a pretty irreverent gang that you
have there and i would think now you
have to direct them they're not going to
take you seriously they're going to give
you a hard time it's hard yeah they're
like a bunch of monkeys these people we
really are crazy i'm one of them
normally on the other side but in order
to kind of command
um some sort of
uh respect for something yeah
i adopted this um jumpsuit the sort of
sweat jumpsuit
i've never been prouder of this country
than i am right now let me tell you
something i am american and you can tell
from that photo
not really no you can't
you could be mocking america i don't
know you're actually right so what's the
bandana all about um well that's also
for a sense of power as well because
it's like it's all axel rose oh you're
you're an axel rose fan oh who me yeah
uh yeah
you the one i'm talking to yeah that's
what i thought
no those people in a row boat out at sea
i was wondering who those guys are um
gnr uh i am a gnr fan we say gnr when
you're like really close tight net
is so easy to say you don't have to go g
and r well you know try to try it it's
nice i just did i didn't like it all
right
so guns and roses the g r guns n roses
fan i love axel right and um actually
for my 30th birthday um i made all my
friends sort of dress up we did like a
fancy dress kind of uh party and i made
everyone dress up as if it was like 1997
you know like a concert for for guns and
roses because i never got to go to that
because right i mean i was given tattoos
but i wasn't allowed to go to gnr yeah
it seems like you could have gone yeah
you were doing all kinds of stuff but
okay so
i think we
i was uh stephanie seymour that's you're
17 and who is playing pixel uh cameron
diaz oh cameron diaz is axel uh i
thought that was axel i was like he's
i want to sleep with axel rose
she um yeah no everyone went all out for
it i was very impressed uh well make
sure i mention this uh this is a very
funny show children's hospital airs at
midnight on thursdays on adult swim
general hospital no idea no clue
is it even on the air anymore i don't
know i'm just worried about luke and
laura yes
everyone should be clap if you get that
reference
[Applause]
very good that was
man you reached back for that one 30
years ago i think i don't know